what is the one thing Mark Zuckerberg
can't buy this is something I was
thinking about a couple days ago I was
arguing with some friends about whether
money can buy truly everything and you
know there's a good case to be made that
maybe you can you can buy you a car buy
you a house we just talked about how it
could buy you political power and PR and
you know all these all these crazy
things you can basically do whatever you
want with impunity even some people
think it can buy happiness but and this
is what I told my buddy there's one
thing it cannot buy and that is a
personality
it can't buy charisma you cannot buy a
sense of humor there are people who try
to do this for a living if you didn't
know they're called media trainers
they're called like PR specialists all
that kind of stuff and there are
channels who specializes see you can go
look up right now like for example
charisma on command right he how would
it be popular as an introvert it
five-way easy ways to show extreme
confidence effortlessly charming you
know whatever basically he analyzes
people who are very you know charming or
whatever and and you know he even has a
quote University where he he teaches
people to be charismatic all its kind of
stuff whatever whenever I look maybe
maybe I'm not trying to rag on the guy
you know he's got his own hustle
whatever it's fair but I don't I don't
believe it works I don't think it works
and let me tell you why because Mark
Zuckerberg is worth sixty nine point
nine million dollars that that's proof I
mean that is that is proof Mark
Zuckerberg has been through so much
media training so much like charisma on
command is just some youtuber there are
specialists in this right who have PhDs
in this stuff I promise you those guys
have been hired by Mark Zuckerberg to
try to make him more palatable like by
the media so people don't just see a
robot every time they see him this guy
this man is worth sixty nine point nine
billion dollars he has every incentive
to be a charismatic leader I have a
personality to not be so weird and this
is what we get this is what we get this
is literally the best money can buy you
kind of need to remind yourself that you
need to focus and and try not to let
stuff bother
as much as possible but it is gonna
bother you because you're human and and
I was human I am human
still um but um put it but I was just
referring to myself in the past um not
that I was look at him look at him oh my
oh oh that is rough he's having a rough
time up there look at that face
Mark Zuckerberg I was human just what
billions of dollars get you in charisma
if you start with a charisma of zero in
life you can't recover there is no
recovering from that you can't train it
even on the moments where his team has
special like guys built things to make
him look cool it's so awkward
[Music]
this is his a is s flirting Jarvis good
morning mark
earlier this year I started building a
simple AI to help run our home I talked
to Jarvis using this app I built it uses
artificial intelligence to understand me
and figure out what to do Jarvis also
helps me get ready in the morning fresh
shirt fire in the hole hell yeah no look
at this leave it fresh shirt siren oh
[Music]
can you imagine if Jeff Bezos or Elon
Musk did something like this it'd be so
much cooler
how does Mark Zuckerberg make a t-shirt
cannon lame it's Mira miraculous how
does he do it let's study let's study
it's just something about the way he
like raises his arm or something I don't
know what it is
fire in the hole and he's like what is
it about
he just that's millions of dollars of
training right there look at that I
don't know what's so wood what's so
weird but I can't even figure it out
it's like he he's maybe it's cuz he's
all shoulder you know he's like this
it's like ya know that's what it is
that's what it is it's look how he
pivots just on his shoulder look look
look look look at this look at this
it's so it's a natural okay hello fire
in the hole did it's so weird I love it
I love it fresh shirt fire in the hole
hell yeah hell yeah dude
millions of dollars for that hell yeah
Oh Mark Zuckerberg you cannot buy you
cannot buy charisma are you seeing what
I'm saying now are you are you
understanding what I'm getting at you
can't buy it you can't do it he's tried
that's what I'm trying to tell you guys
if Mark Zuckerberg cannot buy charisma
with his millions and billions of
dollars
he's got researchers on AI he's at the
cutting edge of social media he
understands you know how people think
all this kind of stuff dude can't even
make a t-shirt can and look cool that's
how bad that's how bad it is hoodie you
know I never take off them I should take
[Applause]
all right yeah this is a great moment in
internet history
what Oh human laughing oh there's
another clip of Mark Zuckerberg receive
look at this and look at this man
billions of dollars billions of dollars
this is a genius Bush Obama and Trump
all use these increasing amounts of data
to focus our activities he's a reptile
he's a reptile and collecting
information Facebook has had this
personal information start receiving oh
man I hope Mark Zuckerberg gets AI gets
the help he needs but it is it is worth
remembering guys it is worth remembering
in a world where so much is controlled
by money and power there's something
they can never take away from us and
that is how to do SH basic human
activities normally smoking a brisket
and some ribs
i am i make meats now smoking these
meats here
smoking it's smoking so I'm the meat
chef yeah someone asked me do I smoke
meat smoking meat smoking these meats
smoking meats earlier in the day smoking
these meats just set the charcoal up and
you set the the wood chips up and that
smoking meats grilling grilling meats
good smoky flavor smoke a brisket for
like 12 hours you smoked lemon chicken
smoked salmon you'll love it bison
sirloin ribs and sausage someone looking
forward to that
[Music]